>> We had a meeting this morning, a lively
discussion of the global gender parity group.
We talked about the issue of maintaining our
commitment to gender parity during a time
of economic stress, we talked about it in
the corporate context. And a major strategy
that evolved was to use the diversity in the
organization as a particular set of skills
or capabilities to address the crisis. Actually
use diversity as a way to address the crisis.
For example, women often times can communicate
and lead teams through a crisis situation,
by reaching out and making an appeal to the
sense of community to deal with the crisis.
As far as a barrier or constraint, we talked
about the fact that a deep crisis creates
a risk aversion and fear and that undermines
the ability of the organization to perform
as a team. And as people get more and more
concerned about their own situation, those
concerns began to dominate the concerns of
the organization. We concluded that it was
very important to renew one’s commitment
to parity and equity in opportunity and promotion
in retention, efforts in talent development
during periods of economic stress.